pas monsieur guénhaël huet merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et porte sur l'abandon du secteur de la
recherche par le gouvernement vous vous
étiez engagé monsieur le premier
ministre à sanctuariser le budget de la
recherche
or un décret d'annulation de crédit
présenté la semaine dernière prévoit la
suppression de 256 millions d'euros sur
le budget de la recherche
une fois de plus votre gouvernement ne
tient pas ses engagements et sa parole
perd le peu de crédit qui lui reste
à l'opposé nos voisins allemands ont
augmenté leurs dépenses de recherche et
de développement de 75 % en dix ans et
le gouvernement américain a décidé de
doubler son effort dans le domaine de la
recherche sur l'énergie
vous prenez donc le chemin strictement
inverse de deux puissants économique
particulièrement compétitive vous
sacrifier la recherche française et
l'avenir des générations futures
alors que nos principaux concurrents
font eux le choix de la recherche et de
l'avenir
sept prix nobel l'ont d'ailleurs très
bien compris puisqu'ils ont dénoncé
publiquement
fait suffisamment rare pour être
souligné ce recul de l'investissement de
l'état dans la recherche par cette
décision vous pénaliser le secteur
industriel français et la recherche
médicale qui n'ont pourtant pas besoin
de cette nouvelle sentence vos décisions
qui manque clairement de vision à long
terme vont accentuer le départ des
meilleurs chercheurs français à
l'étranger
la france fait donc un pas de plus vers
la médiocrité
parce qu'elle renonce à faire les
efforts nécessaires pour rester une
nation d' excellence monsieur le premier
ministre
quand allez vous comprendre que
l'intérêt de la france réside plus dans
le développement de la recherche que
dans l'augmentation de l'aide médicale
d'état
la parole est à madame najat vallaud
belkacem ministre de l'éducation
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
si monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
guen algues et la france est au
cinquième rang des pays de l'osce et des
oeufs en matière d'efforts de recherche
nous en sommes fiers et ce gouvernement
a toujours soutenu la recherche et
continuera à le faire
vous avez évoqué les annulations de
crédits d'un montant de 134 millions
d'euros prévus en effet dans le cadre
des mesures de régulation budgétaire qui
touche sauf exception chaque ministère
ces annulations de crédits ont éveillé
l'inquiétude de la communauté
scientifique vous l'avez justement
rappelé et je veux profiter de ma
réponse pour y répondre en réaffirmant
l'engagement total de ce gouvernement
depuis le début du quinquennat à la
sanctuarisation des fonds pour la
recherche
quel que soit le contexte budgétaire les
annulations qui sont prévus dans le
cadre de ce décret d'avant ce sont des
mesures qui n'auront aucun impact sur
l'activité des organismes de recherche
il s'agit de recalibrer les fonds de
roulement et les trésorerie de ces
organismes
sans que jamais les dépenses de ces
organismes l'exécution de leur budget
les conditions de travail des chercheurs
ne soit affecté les recrutements de
chercheurs ne le seront pas non plus ils
seront maintenues au niveau prévu aucun
programme de recherche ne sera altérée
par ce dispositif de régulation
budgétaire
et j'ajoute même que je m'engage ici 6
734 millions d'euros venait à manquer
aux organismes dans la conduite de leurs
projets à prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour réaborder leurs crédits
les chercheurs les prix nobel en
particulier que vous avez évoquées qui
attire notre attention et nous incite à
être ambitieux budgétairement parlant
pour la recherche ont parfaitement
raison et c'est parce que ce
gouvernement l'a parfaitement compris
que dès le mois prochain une enveloppe
supplémentaire de 65 millions d'euros va
permettre à l'agencé nationale pour la
recherche de retenir davantage de
projets en 2016
cet effort sera porté à 120 millions
l'année suivante c'est parce que nous
l'avons compris que le président vient
d'annoncer que pour le pays à 3 de 10
milliards d'euros
aux 5 milliards d'euros au moins se
consacrer la recherche nice merci la
pole et